lentement très lentement les doses de
vaccins se fraie un chemin vers les pays
en développement
pendant qu'au canada les injections vont
bon train ottawa se permet un coup de
pouce supplémentaire à l'étranger les
demandes des provinces et territoires
pour ce vaccin satisfaites
nous sommes maintenant en mesure de
donner les doses de vaccins
excédentaires le canada donnera plus de
17 millions de doses supplémentaires
d'astrazeneca aux autres pays par
l'entremise du programme kovacs lino
seront produites aux états unis et
envoyait directement à l'étranger
cela porte à 30 millions les dons du
canada provenant de ces surplus de
vaccins le gouvernement trudeau se
débarrasse t-il de vaccins qui a
mauvaise réputation au canada et dont
les provinces ne veulent plus ça fait
penser un peu à tous les les périodes où
il ya eu ce qu'on a appelé du jumping de
médicaments sur le continent africain
ottawa se défend bien sûr que les douze
d'astrazeneca seront utiles astuces à
necker et une vaccin qui premier rang et
est approuvé par santé canada aussi par
la création mondiale tenté mais aussi
assez il y à une grande demande dans le
monde pour astana kayes
mais le programme de partage des vaccins
kovacs a ses limites rappelle cet expert
plusieurs pays ont aussi fait des
intendants privé pour acheter des
vaccins parce que ce n'était pas assez a
dit le grand patron de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé fait patiente et
dénonce la distribution inégale des
vaccins à l'échelle mondiale bottes
writing and i consider grippe
il va même jusqu'à parler de cupidité
dans un camouflet aux pays riches les
efforts du gouvernement trudeau semble
bien timides aux yeux de l'opposition
jusqu'à présent on est presque trop
grand donner 100 millions de doses
on est très loin du compte jusqu'à
présent mais ottawa on voit le signal
que la vaccination à la maison demeure
la priorité si une troisième dose de
vaccin est nécessaire au cours du
prochain mois
le canada aura l'inventaire nécessaire
assure la ministre
canada a levé les vaccins et les
livraisons de vaccins pour cette année
et pour les autres années aussi